I'm always gonna be this for other
people like you that give me my life
well maybe not dereck path could be our
next Bachelor
which is good you know derek has become
the respectful king of this season's
bachelor in paradise everyone always
says oh you're a great guy
that's not I don't want just that I want
to just hear that
[Music]
jeez
[Music]
in the same rejection I've always gotten
there's been speculation surrounding
Derrick's bachelor status after fans saw
how he handled the break-up with Demi
Burnett in Paradise it didn't matter if
it was a man or a woman they'd heard no
differently a source close to the
situation tells ET there has been some
chatter among producers about the
possibility but Derek hasn't gotten an
official offer just yet it's not that
out of the ordinary as for whether the
New Yorker would embark on the journey
the source says he's in a good place and
has grown a lot as a person during his
time on the shows adding Derek is
confident in who he is so he's quote
open to the idea and if he lands the
role he'll be the second VIP contestant
to take on the title but Derek's got
some competition as Peter Webber and
Mike Johnson still seem to be in the
running
Mike weighed in on the possibility when
he spoke with ET earlier this month I'll
be the first black batch so I'll be the
first
- that's a veteran I'll be first Mike
Johnson
so yeah it's more than just being the
first black bachelor based on history
repeats itself I think that Peter looks
the part I think that Peter when he has
a five o'clock shadow Peter looks good
too he'll be a safe bachelor of meaning
that he won't do anything crazy
obnoxious I think it'll be a good safe
clean season if you were to be bachelor
[Applause]